[Applause]
[Music]
on July the 1st 1997 after 155 years of
British sovereignty Hong Kong returned
to China it did so as a special
administrative region under the one
country two systems' model the model
whose goal was to ensure that Hong Kong
would continue being Hong Kong the
freest city on the entire Asian
continent that means that thanks to this
particular political model Hong Kong has
its own laws its own justice system its
own police force its own currency even
has its own customs and immigration
policy that is very different from the
rest of China so in the day-to-day
operations of Hong Kong it works pretty
much as an independent country and well
it's going to remain that way until at
least the year 20:47
maybe that's why since hong kong passed
into chinese hands that things have gone
pretty well in the city over the past 20
years Hong Kong's economy has grown by
an average of 3.3% pay yeah more than 1
million people have moved from mainland
China to this territory in search of
fortune and the city is still an oasis
of freedom
yet the influence and the interference
of the Chinese government in local
politics has grown a lot in recent years
now here on visual politic we already
talked about this for example in past
videos we discussed the umbrella
revolution and Beijing's growing
interference in local politics well as
if you were in the video today we're
going to talk about another standout
feature of this place I mean did you
know that Hong Kong is the city with
some of the most expensive and also the
smallest houses in the world well listen
up
[Music]
a rising market
with seven and a half million
inhabitants and more than 1,200
skyscrapers homes in Hong Kong are
terribly expensive and it's not just
homes garages officers and anything else
that has to do with the real estate
sector is incredibly expensive so much
so that we can find news like this Hong
Kong parking spots sold for record six
hundred thousand US dollars all right so
let's assume that you have a million
dollars and you wanted to buy earned
apartments in one of the city's nicer
areas well in that case you'd barely be
able to afford 22 square meters for 236
square feet and that's for a million
dollars when considering cities with the
most expensive premium homes in the
world Hong Kong places second only
behind Monaco Alibaba chief buys his own
Aladdin's Cave Jack Ma purchases Hong
Kong's most expensive home for one
hundred and ninety three million u.s.
dollars but of course if we take into
account that all kinds of people live in
Hong Kong and skipper Monaco is very
particular case Hong Kong is by far the
city with the most expensive homes in
the world
[Music]
to give you an idea since 2003 the price
of housing in Hong Kong has risen by 450
percent and today the average price per
square metre exceeds sixteen thousand
dollars that's the equivalent of one
thousand four hundred and eighty six
dollars per square foot
yep that means that if you want to buy a
normal 90 square metre house nothing
particularly fancy you have to pay at
the very least one point five million
dollars which is quite the mortgage now
it's very common to compare which cities
are more or less accessible by Counting
how many years of average wages before
taxes we need to buy an average home
well so let's have a look at Hong Kong
according to the latest data in order to
buy a house in Hong Kong you'd need more
than 18 years of full wages for
comparison in cities like Tokyo or
Singapore one needs less than five years
of wages in other words Hong Kong's
situation is totally crazy and not only
that since prosperity is so expensive
and inaccessible Hong Kong's own
citizens they've had to buy smaller and
smaller homes and speaking of small
homes could you guess what the average
surface area for a home in Hong Kong is
what would you guess a hundred square
meters eighty sixty well all of those
figures are sky-high the reality is
that's 42 square meters or 452 square
feet can you imagine living in a house
that's small well in that case check out
the latest trends Hong Kong is so
expensive that architects are building a
hundred square foot tube homes made from
concrete water pipes all right all right
so some of you might now be thinking
well well Simon that's really small but
I'm pretty sure that's because people
live alone in tiny apartments which
alters the statistics right well no on
average almost three people live in a 42
square meter or 425 square feet
apartments which is pretty darn insane
and it's not only the homes the same
thing happens with offices
[Music]
Hong Kong skyscraper sells for record
5.2 billion US dollars but of course
having said that you might now be
wondering well why the hell a home's so
expensive in Hong Kong well listen up
[Music]
the lack of land a myth massive
skyscrapers tiny and ludicrously
expensive apartments this is how we
could pretty much describe Hong Kong
don't you agree
I mean after all we're talking about one
of the most densely populated places in
the world
all right so many people very little
space pretty much a perfect combination
for super high prices right well hold on
just a moment because well dear viewer
this is not the whole truth the truth is
that less than 25 percent that is a
quarter of Hong Kong's territory is
urbanized and only seven percent of the
entire territory is occupied by urban
housing outside the crowded areas we
find countryside jungle old villages
golf courses and many many single-family
homes
[Music]
all righty then so well how is this all
possible well you see for years Hong
Kong was considered to be the freest
economy in the entire world according to
the index of economic freedom we're
talking about a place with low taxes
free trade legal security and a very
small amount of government intervention
yep Hong Kong is a highly capitalist
city that's why it's the third largest
financial center in the world after only
London and New York
by the way fun fact here the basic law
Hong Kong's Constitution limits the
government so that it can't spend more
than it makes this means that the
government usually closes every year
with a surplus indeed this has led it to
save so much surplus that it has over
220 billion dollars in reserve yeah
unlike many many other countries around
the world Hong Kong does not have public
debt our egg but fun facts aside let us
continue the fact is that despite so
much freedom and so much commitment to
capitalism there's a sector in which the
government has intervened a lot and I'm
betting because you've been watching
this video for some time now that you
can probably guess what that is yes it
is the real estate sector you see the
government owns practically all of the
lands in Hong Kong
government authorities control how much
land is put on the market and when it
can be built upon and of course the
development Bureau decides what can and
what cannot be built
now generally land concessions they're
given through auctions these are
generally for private homes officers or
commercial uses or they are done
directly through agreements with
developers when public housing with
lower rental prices is going to be built
which is where a large part of Hong
Kong's population lives
[Music]
and it's normal even in auctions for the
property to continue being government
property as they are granted a right of
use for an unspecified number of years
so sure homes being so expensive in Hong
Kong has a lot to do with scarcity but
it's not due to a geographical shortage
it's due to governmental decision-making
[Music]
there's plenty of lands to develop new
residential and office areas and there's
always the option of gaining ground at
sea yes in Hong Kong reclaiming land
from the sea is not a strange thing to
do indeed a quarter of all the built-up
areas of Hong Kong are on land that was
reclaimed from the sea but the
government they decide absolutely
everything the shortage of land is a
myth there are over 200 hectares of land
available for building in their urban
areas the shortage of housing is real
but that is because of deliberate
manipulation of the market by the
government John Wright barrister and
chairman of friends of Cyclone well in
recent decades as we mentioned before
Hong Kong's population has grown a lot
because many people have come in from
China
in addition family size has decreased
and many Chinese investors want to
invest in this city which is known for
its legal security
all of this has led to a rise in demands
merton not supply this is simply because
the government doesn't want to do it
pom prices will continue to grow due to
limited supply Thomas lamb Senior
Director at night Frank well now the
question has to be well why is the
government interested in restricting
supply and increasing prices well there
are at least two reasons the first is
that auctions are a great business for
the public purse in 2017 for example one
out of every five dollars from public
revenues came from the sale of land and
we're talking here about fifteen billion
dollars the second reason which is much
more sinister is that there are
suspicions of not very clean relations
between the authorities and large
promoters and in some cases these
suspicions have led to convictions hong
kong property magnate thomas kwok back
in jail for bribing city's number two
official you see the real estate sector
in hong kong is held in very few hands
hands that belong to multi billionaires
in fact seventeen of the fourteen
biggest estate magnates in asia are from
this city
[Music]
and well these big businessman preferred
to keep prices sky-high and avoid
competition something that happens when
the government brings very little land
to market and in addition increases any
new projects bureaucracy that way small
and medium-sized enterprises can't enter
the market and foreign companies simply
don't dare to because that have a clear
disadvantage and of course the viewer as
you might imagine all of this as pretty
severe consequences
[Music]
the consequences the crazy price of
housing has meant that despite having a
lot of employment in high wages many
people live in difficult conditions like
families having to live in 40 square
meters that's 431 square feet homes
while paying exorbitant mortgages the
system has also led many people
especially the youngest ones to depend
on the government's public housing and
as you might imagine these are
particularly small and do remember that
in Hong Kong there's no chance of living
on the outskirts or in remote areas
because that would mean crossing over to
mainland China and losing all of the
freedoms that people have in this city
and as if that was not enough the high
price of officers and business buildings
has caused many companies and many
investments to end up in other cities of
the Pearl River Delta such as Shenzhen
which poses problems for the future but
that is a whole view that we could do
another time but anywhere to viewer
that's how things are in the city this
until now has been one of the most
prominent beacons of prosperity and
freedom in Asia only the future is going
to tell us whether this will continue to
be and you know what we're going to be
keeping a very close eye here official
politic but now it's your turn do you
think that Hong Kong's authorities
should encourage growth by increasing
the supply of real estate well leave
your answer in the comments below as
well as in this survey and I really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday also don't forget to check out
our friends at the ricans in the media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]